>> Bret: DAN SPRINGER OUTSIDE
THE AUTONOMOUS ZONE IN SEATTLE,
THANKS.
WE ARE LEARNING ADDITIONAL
DETAILS TONIGHT ABOUT PLANS FOR
POLICE REFORM, THE EPICENTER OF
THE MOVEMENT, MINNESOTA.
CORRESPONDENT MATT FINN IS IN
ST. PAUL TONIGHT.
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO END OF THE
CURRENT POLICING SYSTEM AS WE
KNOW IT.
>> MINNEAPOLIS CITY COUNCIL
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED A RESOLUTION
LAYING THE FOUNDATION FROM
DISMANTLING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND TRANSFORMING THE
CITY’S PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEM.
>> THE WINDS OF CHANGE HAVE
BROUGHT US TO THIS MOMENT.
>> I NEVER WOULD’VE IMAGINED IT
BE WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW,
UNITED BEHIND THIS EFFORT.
>> THE RESOLUTION SAYS POLICE
USE OF FORCE IS AMONG THE
LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH FOR
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR AND COST OF
THE CITY $24 MILLION IN
SETTLEMENTS IN THE PAST THREE
YEARS.
>> PEOPLE IN MINNEAPOLIS ARE
TIRED OF PROTESTING IN THE
STREET EVERY TIME POLICE KILL
SOMEONE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
>> THE CITY COUNCIL WANTS TO
STOP POLICE FROM RESPONDING TO
CERTAIN 911 CALLS BUT THE POLICE
CHIEF TELLS FOX NEWS HE’S GOING
TO MAKE SURE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
ARE FACT-DRIVEN BECAUSE 911
CALLS HIS OFFICERS RESPOND TO
OUR "LIFE-SAVING.
>> WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SHOW UP, I AM NOT GOING TO ALLOW
THIS POLICE DEPARTMENT TO
ABANDON THOSE PEOPLE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO STILL RELY UPON
US AND NEED US.
>> IN LOUISVILLE, KENTUCKY,
CITY COUNCIL VOTED THURSDAY TO
BAN NO KNOCK WARRANTS.
AND SENATOR RAND PAUL INTRODUCED
A BILL TO END THEM NATIONWIDE AS
WELL.
AFTER 26-YEAR-OLD EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIAN BREONNA
TAYLOR WAS A SHOT IN HER
APARTMENT AFTER A NO-KNOCK
WARRANT IN MARCH.
>> ALL BREONNA WANTED TO DO WAS
SAVE LIVES.
>> END IN CHICAGO, 13 POLICE
OFFICERS ARE UNDER INVESTIGATION
AFTER VIDEO EMERGED SHOWING THEM
MAKING POPCORN, DRINKING COFFEE
AND SLEEPING.
IN U.S. REPRESENTATIVE BOBBY
RUSH’S RANSACKED OFFICES WILL
NEARBY BUSINESSES WERE ALLEGEDLY
BEING LOOTED AT THE SAME TIME.
IN MINNEAPOLIS RIGHT NOW,
HUNDREDS OF PROTESTERS ARE
OUTSIDE THE POLICE UNION
BUILDING ONCE AGAIN DEMANDING
ITS CONTROVERSIAL PRESIDENT
RESIGN AND ALSO HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW HERE IN ST. PAUL, THERE IS
AN ONGOING SPECIAL SESSION BUT
SO FAR NO MAJOR MOVEMENT ON
POLICE REFORM.